con preservativos y medicamentos
anticonceptivos en mano pratima cumari
se abre camino entre campos de maíz y
cultivos de piña en kichangán el
distrito con la tasa de fertilidad más
alta de India y uno de los más pobres es
médico y su objetivo es persuadir a Los
Aldeanos de que no tengan más hijos pero
la tarea no resulta nada fácil la
mayoría de la gente aquí es analfabeta
hay tantos conceptos erróneos entre la
gente lo que nos dificulta ayudarlos a
entender estas cosas Esta es la razón
por la cual la tasa de fecundidad es
alta en esta región
curicosis
se trata de uno de los desesperados
intentos para controlar el crecimiento
demográfico en medio de las estimaciones
de la ONU que indican que indias
encamina a convertirse en el país más
poblado del mundo con 1428 millones de
personas este año casi tres millones más
que su vecina china las arraigadas
creencias de una sociedad patriarcal
juegan un rol clave la preferencia de
las familias por tener un hijo varón
hacen que tengan tantos hijos como sea
posible
Esta es mi cuarta niña esperaba un niño
pero no sucedió ahora tengo otra hija
los gobiernos estatales de India han
implementado medidas para frenar el
crecimiento de la población como
programas gratuitos de esterilización
para hombres y mujeres
en el estado más poblado del país las
autoridades propusieron recortar los
beneficios a las parejas que tengan más
de dos hijos como quitarle subsidios
gubernamentales el llamado es también a
la concientización sobre prácticas
culturales desorganizaciones
humanitarias se insta a que mujeres y
niñas no se vean empujadas a matrimonios
forzados y embarazos precoces